america's favorite
sisters who do you think we're in
competition with hmm that's a good
question miley cyrus and noah cyrus
false oh i hate saying the kardashians
what the [ __ ] is going on i
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters sophia and
sistine america's favorite sisters
apparently i know i mean i'm gonna claim
the title already because we're just
gonna it kind of has a nice ring to it
it does we i don't think we've ever
given us a title i know maybe we'll put
it on a hoodie one day
wink wink
subtle nudge for merch you guys today
has been quite the morning um
we were a little bit frantic we were
supposed to have a guest on the guest uh
decided
no thank you to book a trip hope you're
having fun
a little relaxing yeah i'm a little
jealous i hope you're on a beach
with a pina colada in hand
that's the only way i'll think it's okay
but so sofia and i decided you know what
last minute we don't need a guest so you
know we're gonna have a sister episode
okay so
there are so many things we need to talk
about
i feel like we got to catch you guys up
should we just start with finally
the boyfriend met the parents
this has been long awaited
i've had a lot of anxiety about it she
has but i have to say so as he
he was very anxious but it went a lot
better than it went really really well
she came home and she asked me how was
it how was he how were the parents
was it okay was it bad and i think when
you're on the outside of it you can't
really see how it is when you're on the
inside or overthinking it and it went
really well sly talked sly was really
good he was on a rampage of stories he
was throwing out she was the one that i
was the most nervous about because in
the past whenever we brought a guy over
he would always get very kind of cold
standoffish she was just sussing them
out from a distance he would never
really go up to them and make so much of
an effort
in the beginning
i thought okay he's just trying to put
on this persona of being like
overproductive tough guy dad but i asked
him a while ago and i said why do you do
that because it makes him feel extremely
uncomfortable makes me uncomfortable and
he goes no i do that because i know that
that guy wasn't the real deal and i go
really
and he goes yeah and i said so
when a guy comes over
you automatically know right away if
he's going to last and that's why you
don't put an effort and so when he put
an effort with the new guy that i'm
seeing i was like wait so you think it's
gonna last and he said yeah yeah and i
was pretty he's never said that before
yeah he like shits on all of our axes
even if they're super nice he just
thinks it's funny too yeah but you know
my mom's easy to get along with
scarlet's easy i just know him pretty
well but then
i was uh surprised about how comfortable
he seemed your boy it was really good
the house was really uh
panicked right when he rang the gate to
come up
i don't know if you know what mom did no
but literally seconds before he walked
in the door she ran into the bar and was
like sly sly is here he's here there's
been so much buildup right she goes to
my dad
knocks over his bourbon all over the
carpet his ashtray goes everywhere from
his cigar ashes so literally just she's
on the scrubbing the floor trying to
clean up the carpet like seconds before
walking because she's heard how great he
is and how much we all love him yeah so
she's been dying to meet him and not
just through facetime yeah four seconds
and so the real test of the whole night
was
the dinner yeah because you know it
could go either really silent and
awkward it could be really fun and
you've been and i've been both of us to
dinners with significant others families
and it's been unbelievably awkward like
you i remember you told me a story where
you went over to not your boyfriend's
place it was a while back and you guys
had to pick questions out of a jar oh it
was a conversation this was so weird oh
my god i was a sophomore in high school
we weren't even dating i think i just we
just had a crush on each other anyway he
invites me over for dinner with his
family it was super weird the mom was on
the phone so dinner was ready and the
dad goes we cannot start dinner until
she gets off the phone and she was on
the phone for 45 minutes so we were all
sitting at the table for 45 minutes
waiting for her to get off the phone but
she knew it was dinner and if that
wasn't awkward enough eating cold steak
we
uh
there was no conversation there was a
deck of cards in the middle of the table
and without even explaining anything the
dad starts he picks up a card and reads
the card and it says something like
if you could make your room any color
what would it be
and we would go around the table and i
was like uh purple like it was just so
awkward so awkward yeah you can tell the
vibe in ins instantaneously once you sit
at dinner yes exactly and so it was
great it was great instantly everyone
was nice and fun and talking and
laughing i was
stress eating the whole time i know you
were i had three slices of pizza two
helpings of pasta i was just getting
nervous i kept stuffing my mouth with
food yeah just giggling on the side all
i could tell you you were so nervous
when you when you get nervous you don't
talk and she'll just kind of have these
weird outbursts of laughs well first
impressions are everything yeah i just
wanted them to see
how much i like him and how great of a
guy he is and i just got nervous and
overwhelmed but the conversation was
funny it did end in
my parents completely just exposing how
much of a loser i was in my early years
so me too we really should talk to each
other the entire oh my god
self-deprecating is our
crime we couldn't do that in two seconds
this boy heard stories about how strange
of a child i was even in high school so
i wasn't a child things that he didn't
even need to hear no and i was like you
know what is that just a thing that
families do when you bring like when
someone brings over a guy like you just
go automatically
let me tell you the story about when
tony was four yeah
himself it's the stereotypical oh let me
bring out the baby photos embarrass the
other person just to make them feel a
little bit more welcome exactly it works
it did work and you know why it worked
at the end of the night
sly goes up to him
gives him a firm handshake of approval
said it was really nice to meet you
all this stuff and i was like whoa there
we go he's never done that before if
you're ever introducing someone to your
family i would just note this i think
why it also went really well is we never
spoke any i mean there's no reason to
speak negatively about him but there was
no negative things about him in the
relationship so when he came in only
positive so everyone was expecting just
the nicest person in the world and so i
remember times where i would speak
poorly about someone i was going on with
and then they would come over and they
had different oh yeah yeah
we all we already hate him exactly so i
think that was another big thing that we
made sure to do which is speak just good
good good good to him for sure no it's
nice to get the first one out of the way
yeah so let's talk about your morning
the other day when you
scared the [ __ ] out of me yeah it's
scary okay i
yeah this is i hate social media my
snapchat was hacked
yes and the thing is is that the last
episode actually had happened and i
didn't really want to talk about it
because i was really pissed and i was
freaking out and i don't know i don't
know if the person's watching this and
is just super content with the fact that
he hacked it or whatever but i woke up
and my phone was popping off calls and
emails and texts saying uh your snapchat
has been like logged into change the
password da da da if this is not you
and i lost it i'll tell you something
and i'm just gonna preface this it's
gone i deactivated it deleted every
single photo and video so if you guys
try to get in you get nothing so i went
on to my account
i know and i by the way it was kind of
cool snapchat sent the ip address and
the location and the device that was
being used to hack into my account this
is so why but that is why i don't even
trust icloud yeah the fact that you can
find someone's exact location through
snapchat that's too successful that's
because it's signed into a new thing
which i think they should do that
because now i have no it's good
occasional
find you but why i was freaking out in
the morning is one i've never been
hacked you have been hacked with your
phone before i've been like twice but my
snapchat is private it's only my closest
friends i don't use it ever but i use it
to record videos save photos of really
stupid stuff nothing
like no but
or whatever
when you go out with your girls and you
take embarrassing drinking videos
exactly ugly you know things of your
family just because my instagram is
public my my twitter i don't ever use it
but that's public and so this was the
one thing for me i could just have to go
back on memories and i have had it since
like 2016. so it had everything on there
like everything and so
i freaked out because i didn't remember
what i had on it
at all and so i was thinking did i take
something that could be leaked which i
know i don't but you i just don't
remember is it something bad that i
could have said i don't think so because
i don't remember anything like that so i
went through every single photo and
video and there were hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of those
throughout the morning freaking out i
ran into sistine's room crying let me
tell you there's nothing scarier than
waking up to
horrific crying screaming it's not like
that i thought someone died
what would you guys think like you get
woken up with her running into the room
crying saying sistine i'm freaking out i
was like who died that was my first
thought and then she said my snapchat
died and i was like well
okay yeah that's not i mean well you've
got she all right she gets it because
once you are hacked it does freak you
out because who by the way it's such an
invasion of privacy oh totally it's so
invasive and i felt so vulnerable in
that moment and i haven't really
felt like that because out of everything
on my instagram i am pretty
i mean if all my friends know me i'm
like a hawk with all of it at least it
was just your snapchat though
yeah well no
honestly out of everything yes instagram
would be really no i'll tell you mine
was pretty bad they got all of my
contacts my messages and my photos and i
got all of theirs um i didn't even
realize this part
they were dming my ex-boyfriend oh yeah
this is funny this is so funny so wait
this is actually this is funny so
when i'm deleting everything even on my
eyes only everything has gone wiped out
so screw you you found nothing um i went
on to the messages part and i was
looking at if they had sent anything
yeah the only thing
the only person they decide to send a
message to it out of all the friends i
have on that list
is my ex-boyfriend whoever knocked out
that's a pretty success
savage move on stalker's fart i
was losing my mind i said out of every
one of everything you could have done
right now let's make it worse it was
almost like he went on the account just
to reach out to him but the funniest
part is
sophia writes a message to him saying
look i'm really sorry i got hacked this
morning that wasn't me messaging you
through snapchat i'm sorry you have to
deal with this and his immediate
response was yeah no worries i thought
it was weird that you were messaging me
anyway so i just blocked you right away
so he literally without even knowing
what i was you
what if i just wanted to talk to you
through snapchat i was like no no
there's no way sophia would message me
so it's gotta be an automatic block
blocked and i noticed it on my phone i
was like wait now it's all gray like why
is it great on my snapchat and i
realized like he blocked me maybe the
account was harassing and he blocked no
no it wasn't because he hadn't even
opened it by the way he's just because a
message popped up
he blocked me what did you do to this
poor boy
ah what happened
you are savage little that is savage
that so that just freaked me out i
deleted snapchat i'm never using that
again i just realized i'm not going to
use a lot of social media accounts
because
it's freaking too much if you think
about some of the biggest celebrities
with the highest following like they've
all gone
everyone no one's safe out there guys no
so if you guys do have an account with
anything
delete
anything that you think can get leaked
honestly don't really send nudes no also
have like four
password uh
levels you know you can do two factor
exactly yes exactly have like eight of
those
just do that for fun so just keep it
safe because you know i never thought
this would happen and it did and it was
a private account that no i've never
publicized
something i just remembered when i got
hacked and i got all of that person's
photos and texts and whatever
the only photo
in their camera roll i am not kidding i
still have it on my computer i can show
it i will put it up
it is a photo of course this would
happen to me like the eeriest thing ever
it looks like a dark basement think like
american horror story basement right
that's for your vibe
i know
a really rusty old carousel
and a little girl riding it
not kidding it is still oh my god a real
little a real little girl like a
three-year-old riding a carousel in the
dark in a basement i just got chills
from that uh
if that would be
anyone's swap a photo it would have
got his name
i actually do have his name and his
address
we should have him on the show
we should pull their hackers on the show
so why'd you do it
so girl is that what you're looking for
um okay in lighter news yeah oh my god i
sound like a newscaster i know you kind
of your your transitions are pretty
it's okay guys i'm so excited yeah no
this is big i'm so excited drum roll
please
tonight we're going on a double date
baby this is very exciting i think
sophia is only excited i'm so excited
because she's going on a date with me
yes okay so
kind of so i i've been third wheeling
their relationship since it started
larry since day one and so i don't mind
it though yeah like a tricycle yeah
we've always talked about how we wanted
to go on a double date and we've been on
double dates before and they've been so
much fun and what makes it better is the
guy that you're going on the date with
is best friends with my boyfriend yeah
so there's no way
this is a recipe for success yeah not
disaster there's no way it could go
wrong no and i was saying to christina i
was like she goes are you excited are
you nervous and meet him i said you know
yes and no whatever it feels like a
first date but i am so stoked to be
going out with you guys because i want
to see how it is in that dynamic so
let's talk let's do girl talk right now
what are you gonna wear because wearing
a first date outfit
is
very strategic yeah you know you got to
give off the right first impression
i used to be the girl that would try to
look overly sexy
and then it kind of just gave off the
complete opposite vibe of what i was
going for i still try to give off the
vibe of being over released no but i
i've changed my approach to dressing
more classy and sophisticated and then
they always prefer that later on like
whenever i'll ask like oh what was the
outfit you remembered or do you remember
what i was wearing on the first date are
you guys ever gonna remember the exact
album oh god guys
my guy remembered
really because it was a good outfit
case clothes which one was it i was
wearing a skirt blue kitten heels a
black raft top and a blanket because he
looks like a school girl of course he
thought that was hot oh yeah i did huh
damn it
i was like i dressed like kate middleton
very classy sure she's like super
sophisticated mini skirt
a laptop blazer
i covered when i went outside so boss
move yeah so what are you gonna wear
um well i always like to dress according
obviously to the restaurant and this
one's a bit more chica i feel like it's
very a lot of young 20 year olds yeah
all of my friends have been to this
place a hundred times i've taken you on
a date there my friend gabby is sitting
over there i've taken her on a date
there i think it's gonna be maybe
sophisticated but sexy i want something
maybe a little bit bodycon but high
necked
maybe short maybe long i don't a dress
for sure i love dresses so so you want
something a high turtleneck business on
the top body arty on the bottom
exactly
exactly so you're gonna go for like a
long tight dress i want his imagination
to run wild but also be like because but
you're leaving nothing to the
imagination it is imagination you're
showing every curve i'm showing the
silhouette i'm not showing the goodies
okay
okay and also if i wear something long
and high-necked i don't have to tan my
whole body because my arms
the things that are exposed the things
we do okay so you're gonna wear that
yeah but you know what i also um
realized is that i've never been on a
double date blind date
because
i know blind dates are you don't you've
never uh
maybe seen the person yes but i've seen
him but i've never talked to him i've
literally never talked to him we went to
school like for a year together but yeah
he was way cooler than me
i was hiding in the library eating
muffins so he definitely didn't know me
um and so i i yeah so i don't know even
what to expect it's probably like you're
the girl that gave us the shortage of
muffins at school you're the girl that
drink the vitamin water the blackberry
one every single day like i always
wanted a double chocolate chip muffin
and you ate all of them you're the girl
that had to die on the first day of
school
that's also a story we told her
boyfriend during the time they met the
parents which is sophia had a massive
style that's a good story time okay so
you know what you're gonna wear
yeah i already know you know what you're
gonna order
oh yeah i've been to this place a lot
but i'm not i can't i have to be a
little bit
cool and chill i'm so chill i mean you
can't order a pizza if you're cool and
chill what does that mean
but uh oh oh can you do this for me what
okay when you go to the bathroom just in
the middle of dinner okay tell the
waiter to send me a drink
and pretend it's from another guy
and so the drink comes over and it's
gonna look like i'm desired by
many of the men in the restaurant so
then this guy
thinks he doesn't have his grips on me
this sounds a little toxic
but it also sounds like it would work
i'm loving it think about that plan
you're cooking up just a cute little it
can be like a little shot but like a fun
fruity shot
you know but you know what
this guy from what i've heard no no no
it doesn't matter about the shot if it's
a shot of a cocktail or a champion
but this guy from what i've heard
doesn't sound like a player or a guy
that you don't know that yeah your
boyfriend is going to say to you
everything positive about it it could
have what i'm saying is it could have a
reverse effect
it could be like oh
like she can't focus on what's happening
here maybe her eyes were wandering and
caught eyes with another guy or
you never know no because what guy i
would send a drink to a girl that is
clearly on a double date that is so
messed up a guy that
i want to go out with no you don't have
to date yourself that's true that's
right i could backfire but i also think
it's a great idea so um just have that
in
if the date looks like it's going poorly
okay
ramp it up and do that do you have any
conversation
starters if it does go flat
yeah you know we always have those
go-to's yeah but those are bad
new ones we can't say facts like we're
no well by the way because it's a double
date i'm
banking on you and your boyfriend to
pick up the energy if he's lacking i
know i'm not lacking
i'm a talker i will talk your ear off no
yeah really
yeah
i will but i i feel like you and
you
we're going to cut that we go oh god
you and the boy that you're going out
with um
need to help me out here i got you yeah
so what are you gonna do if it goes well
you know i like to sort of make you
uncomfortable so now we you have to make
me seem like the coolest funnest but
you're not no you
sistine but you might as well be honest
early on in the relationship you're not
the funnest coolest girl
you're
horrible you're stye muffin girl
not anymore no wear it with pride wear
it on your sleeve like a badge of honor
i oh no so the thing is i said this to
mom because i said i went to that's how
i was before i feel like my inner
muffin girl is gonna come out because i
you said
i hope he never hears this but i used to
have a crush on him from afar of course
afar because i couldn't get near him
with my style
i would literally infect him i would
infect him on you so from afar
so
it's just now i'm getting like giddy i
feel like i'm in high school i know yeah
wow oh god but so i i had this idea to
make you know i i you know we have i
love research you know i love to do that
i love to look up what's the best
outcome like what i can do to make sure
that this date will be a success yeah to
set yourself up for success so i looked
up some research notes to see
scientifically what guys are into so
that i have a better chance and i also
did it for men and i just want to note
before i start saying all these stuff
yeah where did you get this scientific
research the internet did you get it
from cosmopolitan.com no i got some from
men's health okay i'm from
like like a like a love
website sure we'll see how we'll see at
gq badgirlsbible.com
look at that website has been a very
interesting one that you still subscribe
to for some reason i can't unsubscribe i
keep getting the emails it's really
quick bad girls club whatever no no
first of all i didn't put my email in
this girl that i went to one lunch with
was crazy put my email in so now i can't
unsubscribe and every day i have to read
you some of the headlines they are
so gnarly and sexual just gross so
sexual okay go okay so um no
this is a joke note that this is for
girls that like guys and guys like girls
if i don't this is just from that i just
don't want to like take anyone out of
the situation but just letting you know
yeah that is it okay so for
women do you want me to start with what
men need to know or what women need to
know do women okay what women need to
know
according to a study
men rate and we've said this before
woman in red as more sexually attractive
than women wearing other colors
red yeah because it's kind of peacocking
which is oh
excuse me peacocking
yeah but you know what that means i
understand that like that's why well
yeah because it it's such a funny word
yeah because it shows you're confident
your loudest in the room you're
basically the center of attention
i know and so they also have preferred
red lipstick because men gazing at red
lipstick for 7.3 seconds compared to 6.7
seconds for pink lipstick and i will
just be saying this i ain't wearing red
lipstick on a date because i'm going to
look away 60 years old
i would love to know how they got these
statistics and numbers yeah right were
they just counting was the guy counting
like how do they have six seconds versus
seven seconds i don't know there's a
study i found online okay uh men have a
preference for women who show off their
long arms
we do have long limbs that's for sure
so my wingspan is i don't know what it
is about arms men that you're attracted
to but i will be showing off my arms
tonight
and so the next one is vanilla scent is
the most desirable and that's all you
want to learn and i love a vanilla scent
i love men's cologne she does she has a
musk
i like to smell like an ashtray she does
yeah just honestly blokes cigars smoke
on her and she'll wear it out yeah
that's a good one
um a dress or anything sleeveless is
what men prefrontal one of the arms also
what is that what's with your guys in
collar bones
is that oh collar bones i get but arms i
don't like my arms i got man shoulders
you don't
i also don't like seeing an armpit like
that makes me uncomfortable i don't like
the stubbles i know some women like to
like keep it on shape that's fine do you
i don't know but we're all hypocrites i
guess i like to keep it waxed uh then i
read this
men like knowing a woman has a set of
golf clubs so should i
what are these we got a guy we got a guy
behind the camera saying no
that doesn't matter i need to subtly
bring up the hold on do you prefer
tennis rackets maybe tennis rackets oh
yeah yeah he prefers tennis rockets okay
golf clubs golf clubs
maybe because golf is a
sophisticated hard sport that like a
select few can do which makes you more
special yeah i guess so and then lastly
26 of men i love this this is my thing
love women with a well-stocked bookshelf
damn it yes
so if i say i have golf clubs show off
my decollete wear red vanilla perfume
show off my books
that's a lot of things to do yeah
that's a lot mm-hmm
mm-hmm
and then for men i thought this is
interesting what women find attractive
because of course we have male listeners
and i think they want to know also what
i want right yeah so you can tell your
boyfriend this 58 of women want a guy
that can make her laugh
and they're three times more likely to
give out their number if you do
just letting you know so if you can make
a good joke they'll give you your number
two that's so true yeah if you have any
of these five jobs apparently this is
the sexiest um they said first
medical dental or veterinary fields
what
medical yeah
dental no veterinarian
about that legal fields okay
self-employed which i don't know
whenever i see self-employed on hinge i
always kind of go
no whenever a guy on hinge says tech
startup like you're developing and i
love that no that means he has an app
that he's never actually developed but
he's like i have an idea for an app
that's what tech started means on a date
not all of the okay no fair the next one
is politics or military okay i could see
the appeal with it like yeah for the
military yeah for sure and then the last
one is teachers and professors
i don't know how i feel about those
lists that kind of threw me off
you know what for me be a dj or a
librarian
a dj
oh so yeah inside joke
is it
is it perhaps you really do like djs
maybe you should give diplo a call
he does follow me and you oh god um okay
next is 51 percent of women like the
pudge
pudge pudginess oh i think he meant i
think he said pug okay
yeah so women like dad bots i've been
saying this since day one 51
more i'll tell you why
because when you're cuddling with a guy
that is rock hard it is so uncomfortable
it's true it's like cuddling with a
statue it is it's like i'm sitting on a
pile of rocks i don't like it
i want my head to sink in at least an
inch
to a stomach
i want to hug something cuddly
and not i want to be a tempurpedic
mattress without squeezing it just like
memory foam like i push his arm and then
the indent stays for a little bit and
then it comes back dehydrated
i love that we love it that means your
veins show more so that means 51 percent
of women so
have a little onion
i think i think dad bods are great yeah
you know what i was waiting you know
what dad bought tells me you like to
have fun
that's
that's what it tells me
i'll tell you why because actually
that's good i'll tell you why when a guy
is too ripped
he has way too much time on his hands to
go to the gym and only have whey protein
that doesn't sound fun at all egg whites
and and that means they're gassy which
is like i don't want to be around that
that's true now if i see a dab bod you
don't care if you
go lizzy
a few nights a week maybe go get a beer
go to the game yeah like work out what
three four days a week great you're not
like living your life around your body
and then i think you get hyper focused
on what you look like all the time a dad
bothers without letting it hang she's so
passionate about
living their best life okay well
i guarantee were you in the study oh
probably you're only one of the people
that said yes i want a veterinarian dad
bod
okay so another one is this is there's
two more
women find dressing well to be one of
the most attractive things for sure
so if you're going to wear shoes wear
sneakers over dress shoes though
okay yeah definitely um and then out of
the 800 women what they should wear on a
first date they said something casual
but chic
they said
faded vintage style jeans faded vintage
style jeans and then this is kind of
weird
tell me this is weird because i think i
would not like this 63 percent think men
who wear scarves
are hot
that is a hard note for me
i'll tell you
i'll tell you it i'll tell you ink right
now the scarf
that doesn't have ends and it's just the
circle
that was because i used to own those
and you just keep wrapping it and
wrapping it and it gets so tight
i see people wear it i hate it so i hate
it so much what is it
that's not a scarf no i don't know why i
have this image in my head of a guy
wearing light wash vintage jeans singing
in a cafe with a tube scarf on like
thinking he's [ __ ] european or
something like drinking a cappuccino a
scarf if you're cool in new york and
it's kind of hanging over your shoulders
with a trench coat that's swag that's
why when you're in california there's a
scarf
no no no you're a beach bum yeah i was
like i was thinking they had to all be
in new york if they were answering these
questions oh i i've never seen anyone
wear a scarf here a scarf or like one of
those small scarfs
that's a girl thing you want to know
something crazy i went on a date with a
guy
that
oh my god i have the image burned and i
hate it so much you know those jeans
first of all his jeans were way too
tight i think they were tighter than my
jeans
and they were light washed like almost
white denim but they were light blue and
it had those patches on the thighs and
the calves that have ridges on it
oh like a motorcycle oh i know exactly
what you're talking about
you see those in biker jackets you get
it at like hot topic in 2001. maybe he
was from the past and
just came in the future he was still
whoa he came out of the womb wearing
those jeans yeah that was bad he hasn't
updated and then also 48 said that men
who are pink are hot and confident
pink men wear pink i actually like a man
in pain i do too i i don't mind it i
don't mind it and you know what's so
funny why do you guys get so triggered
when you say oh like your pink shirt and
he's like it's salmon
who's ever said that team
actually no one i think you saw that on
friends
yeah joey joey from friends told me that
oh yeah
oh god that's when we watch too much tv
so men with big hands says for women men
that have big hands
correlates to sexual
uh power i've been saying that hands are
the best okay the last thing is oranges
lemons grapefruit smell have had a clean
energizing
uh feel to them that is good for you and
women's libidos
fun fact
oranges increase oxytocin is it oxytocin
oxytocin ptosis testing levels which
make women want to bond
bond bond wait so i don't think a guy's
gonna go out and buy like a lime
flavored cologne now
from this
yeah probably not and also i don't think
i'd
prefer a smell
of limes and lemons on a guy no i
wouldn't even notice but here's the
thing normally i don't have good
feelings about your dates but this one i
have a great feeling and have it been
right yes every time that's true she has
so we'll keep you updated and i'm
excited for it she's gonna get hammered
we always love to do unsolicited advice
and we haven't done one in a bit and
sustained brought in
and understood nice this is from
victoria
shealy and let me just say really quick
if you guys want your questions answered
you go to the apple podcast page five
stars write your question in the reviews
and also just subscribe while you're at
it because you know we love the
subscribers and i know people say this
all the time but it actually is really
really really helpful for us if you are
supporters and love this show i have to
say you guys have been doing a great job
because i checked this morning we read
the comments all the time and we have
five out of five stars now should we
really yes yes we do finally
i know we love it yeah also a lot of
people are wanting us to bring back
bedtime stories so if you want us to
read your bedtime story make sure you
submit your story in the email which is
unwalkspodcast gmail.com
i think there's a couple emails on there
it's in our instagram bio unwaxed
podcast so submit it there and then
we'll read it on the show we'll do it
next week maybe so here is the question
first of all i've left the podcast since
the very beginning i discovered your
podcast after your second episode went
live oh my god a true wow i love
her truly feels like i'm hanging out
with the sisters i never had okay here's
her question
what are your anagrams i don't know what
that is what are your anagrams and
zodiac signs so i know we always talk
about zodiac signs and sistina are big
fans of it i know that i'm probably one
that just gets obsessed with knowing
exactly what my son moon rising i got
sistine into it yes um and
she i don't remember what your rising is
i'm pulling it up right now um i am a
virgo sun
aquarius moon and gemini rising
uh and that's kind of funny i was going
out with a guy and sistine's signs were
exactly the same as his and they hated
yeah he's my twin flame i'm basically
mgk and megan fox with him but i hate
him yeah that's true you know who you
are
so my sign is cancer i'm a rising libra
and my moon is in leo now i couldn't
tell you what any of that means
it's not good things oh they said it's
not a good thing no it's all good so
moon in leo
rules your emotions moods and feelings
my emotional self is dramatic proud
expressive idealistic and self-centered
that is
so true
and
libra
uh i wear a mask when i present myself
to people
that's no that's what the rising is so
rising is basically how you are in front
of people so compromising courteous
fair-minded though passive-aggressive
uh you may seem inclined towards balance
in all forms aesthetic romantic and
judgment
and just
can adapt to any person situation
dog cat woman
old person yeah because it's like the
double the two i would say ours are very
accurate to us they are very accurate i
i like her signs because that's the
reason why this show works really well
is because she has a completely
different personality than i do but i'm
sorry we couldn't answer your anagram
question cece hasn't taken the test
i know mine's enfj we can make her take
it you actually should take it she likes
taking these i love quizzes you should
definitely do it but thank you guys so
much for coming back every single week
to hear us talk and
debate and argue and give you the worst
advice ever
but you're gonna wanna tune into next
week's episode
let's just say we'll have two butts in
this couch
and they might be related to us
so it's gonna be a great episode we will
see you guys next tuesday bye
[Music]